J233, how you doing? Oh, I thought that
that Hi, James the name. Yeah. Oh, yeah,
it is. I I had to make sure. I had to I
I had to just make sure. Yeah, I just
choose my other email. Hi. How are you
doing? I'm doing great. Thank you for
asking. Good. Welcome back. Yeah, thank
you. Hi, David. Hi, Jay. And hey, Jane.
Nice. We came just for you. Yes. Nice to
meet you. Oh, that's so sweet. Thank
you. Yeah, but I drug them. I drug him
all the way here. Oh, thank you so much.
So, I just want to start by asking a
question. Okay. How dare you not have
taps? Oh, yeah. Good point. Just it blew
my mind when I heard that. It was really
funny. I should have had it in my back
pocket. What was I What was I thinking?
Yeah. So, um I don't know. Um I don't
know what like to start with. I have a
lot of questions. I do. And yeah, let's
start just by the first thing. I would
love to know what you guys think of the
Sabbath in the Quran. I don't know if
that makes sense. It's in surah and it
specifically mentions um the Sabbath and
I was thinking to myself or like my own
understanding of that was that God is
telling them um to not my own
understanding actually this is what the
verse says. Let me just pull that up for
a second. What verse is it? Basically
Allah I'm not sure. I'm sorry. I'm just
going to try to pull it up. It's the
only thing I don't have in hand. Yeah.
See, how dare you? You see, you see
what's here say about this? It might be
265. Yeah. 265. Is it that one?
265.
Can you I'm sorry. Can you Can you say
it out loud? Uh, yeah. Do this one, I
think. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, it is. Yeah,
this one. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. So, uh, am I
mistaken or actually So, this is like
I'm actually I don't know because I
looked up the tier and stuff like that,
but it didn't explain it. Why would God
or like Allah in the Quran uh bring up a
verse that is specifically about a
Sabbath that God declines in the Quran?
So basically the Sabbath was the day
that God rested and God doesn't rest in
Quran or like in Islam. He never took a
day to rest. He finished the entire
earth or like the entire world in 6 days
and he didn't rest. Am I correct or am I
wrong? That's what I want to know. Uh
correct. He says in another verse um
that we we never rested. Um yeah,
exactly. Yeah, I don't know. Do you know
Arabic? I do. Yeah, I speak Arabic. I
just refrain from doing that because I
don't want my dialect to be known. Oh,
sure, sure. Um, okay, that's fine. Um,
yeah. So, he says that in
surah um surah 50:38 um he said that
yeah 50:38 he says we we um so he didn't
he didn't have a rest day. So the Quran
the the Quran mistakes the rest. He
thinks that rest is because of
tiredness. So in surah 50:38 he said we
never had no tide. So he didn't he
didn't have a rest. So you're right. So
that is you know that's smart. So you
see the you see the issue here. Yeah.
Good contradiction. Yeah. This is going
to sound weird because you guys are are
like Christians but is it actually a
problem? Because I feel like I'm kind of
losing my senses when it comes to
spotting contradictions. So is it is it
actually weird that it's like mentioned
because I it's not making sense. like
why would you mention something like
that when you refuse it at the same
time? Um that's a good question to ask
the religion but I'll tell I mean I'll
tell you what what I think my theory is
that Muhammad just heard stuff and he
didn't know what it meant. So um sept in
in in Arabic just means Saturday. So I
don't think he realized the implications
of it. He just thought oh the Jews make
a big deal of it so it must be something
in their Torah that Allah gave them to
do. and he didn't realize that in
somewhere else he went against it.
That's what I think. I don't know what
the rest of the panel think. Yeah, I
think that um it's it's something that
points out how the Quran uh is is one it
doesn't know what what it's talking
about. And at the it confirms something
that it contradicts at the same time.
This is another example. It confirms the
Sabbath but you know uh uh like
undermines everything that the Sabbath
is and its origin, right? So it it
contradicts what it confirms at the same
time which is just another part of
showing the Islamic dilemma. So yes,
it's another problem. This just this is
just another example of that. There's
there's many there's a lot of them.
Okay, so uh I have another thing that I
don't want to forget about. So you guys
were like on your life like I don't know
two months ago or something. You were
talking about a list of prophecies that
were fulfilled in Jesus and you had it
on hand. So would that be a reasonable
question for I think that was J&D. Would
that be reasonable for you to send it to
me? Of course. Yeah. Yeah, we can
definitely send it to you. You still
have it? Yeah. Um I'm trying to think
the specific list that we had, but we
can definitely get one and there's a lot
of them out there. But yeah, we can
definitely send it to you. There there
are many many prophecies like as we
talked about that are fulfilled in Jesus
and that's a great way to prove that he
truly is the Messiah and that the Bible
is reliable. And if you read Matthew if
you read Matthew uh it's the gospel
that's excellent. So it talks about
these prophecies. Um if if you find
notes towards the bottom of your Bible,
it says for example like for example, he
was born in Bethlehem and then it tells
you like a footnote saying this is this
comes in a prophecy and
another whole Bible. You go back to
these. So Matthew is a good book to read
and cross check all the prophecies all
the prophecies that Matthew talked
about. Yeah, I think that's kind of
already what I'm doing. I'm reading like
I started with John and I wrote down
everything that was like like just a
second that was related to um Jesus
deity or like the the claims of like or
like Jesus teachings in it. So I'm doing
this a book like what do I say like how
do I say this? Um I'm taking it one at a
time. I started with the gospels because
I already read the entire Bible before
but it was like for my MA so it didn't
count for me like I didn't actually get
any information from there. Uh but I
think it's just the mental like um it's
kind of overwhelming to go through these
things. So I feel like I just want
something to read. I I'm done like
making things on my own or like you know
searching things for my own which is why
I'm like can you please help me because
it's like it's really overwhelming for
me.
who reads through stuff with you. If
you're reading something for the first
time also, um so we've put our email
address for you in the in the private
chat, you can email us. Um you can email
me, you can speak to me Arabic or
whatever you like. Um I can and we can
send you what we have and we can even
like do a reading study verse by verse
and go through prophecies slowly so you
you absorb it. It will take some time.
Extremely helpful. Thank you so much. Um
so another thing that I would like to
know your opinion about is the
antichrist. Um I already talked to like
Avery about this on his life and from
what I understand antichrist is a figure
representing ultimate or like like
opposition to Christ and his teachings.
Is that correct? That's right. Mhm. So c
can I ask you because I know that you
were like you grow up a Muslim. Um, is
it like I feel like I'm kind of
affirming my own thoughts, which I got
to stop doing that. Um, yeah, let's
let's just get back to your topic, you
guys, because I feel like I'm wasting
your time. No, no, you're not wasting
time. You can ask your question. I feel
like Yeah, it's it's not that's the
problem. It's not as a question as it's
like affirming my own thoughts, which
you have a thought about the antichrist
and you you want to get our thoughts on
it? It's fine. Yeah, it's not that. It's
just the fact that there is an
antichrist in Islam. And for me, that
doesn't make sense. I already spoke
about that before, which is why is there
an antichrist? Because an antichrist is
someone that opposes the teachings of
Christ. And the only way that we can get
the teachings of Christ historically is
through the Bible. And it says
everything against the Quran. And it
just doesn't make sense. So, I wanted to
know if there's if there was an Islamic
like explanation for it because from
what I've got, there is none. It It's
kind of interesting because when you
look at what the Islam says the
antichrist is going to be like, it says
like he compares it to Allah actually,
which is kind of funny because the
antichrist, like you said, it's the
anti- messiah, like the anti but it
compares it to Allah like it says this
is not like your Lord, like one eye like
your, you know. So yeah, it's it's you
have I think I know where you're coming
from with that. And it does point the
the fact that the antichrist exists in
Islam does and the descriptions of the
antichrist does point to actually the
messiah being God rather than not being
God. Yeah. It says so it's the exact
word is I wanted to say that. Yeah.
Yeah. And they actually don't say it
like that. They say it
with the lying messiah. So um again I
think Muhammad just heard that that uh
from Christians around or even you know
people of the book around and then he he
and they were talking about that in end
times you know when judgment comes and
so he said oh okay so I have to put that
in my religion also that there will be
an antichrist but he didn't realize that
when he said antichrist
um there's a there's a context and that
there is a Christ then and all about
Christ and antichrist is not about any
other religion. So I think again he kind
of told on himself a bit but it's
because of ignorance that's so by the
way the email is in the private chat so
we can send you the list of prophecies
and other things we can set some other
things up with you as well. That would
be amazing. Thank you so much because
that's one of the things that I'm
looking for. Okay. I just took your
email. I'm going to be emailing you
after like this live. Okay. Great. Okay.
So um to get back to your topic which is
the Islamic dilemma. Um, what how can I
share my screen if that's okay? Because
um like you press the present button. Oh
yeah, that makes a lot of sense. Just
just be careful though if this is like
your first time doing this. You don't
want to share anything that you don't
want people Exactly. Yeah. I mean it's
all like I think it's all safe so it's
okay. Okay. Put your hand on the screen.
No.
My camera is closed. Okay. Yeah. So you
push present and then what chrome what
tab you want to share or Yeah. Exactly.
I found it. Here it is. Thank you. Yep.
Does it is it like appearing to you
guys? Let me do it. It's on the screen
now. So, I tried to write my own. Wait,
I think I lost. Yeah, I think this is
it. Yeah. So, this is um the verses that
troubled me. So what I did was I looked
up all the verses that I started with
the Torah and I like I wrote down all
the like, you know, just the arguments
about it and then I would write down if
this verse affirms the authority and
preservation of the previous scriptures
or not. So far until this one. Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. I'm sorry you
guys. Um, you you guys are kind of
lagging. Are you saying anything? No.
Yeah, we're good.
nature. So yeah, I think until this
point, I think this is where it started
getting messy for me. Um, it's like I
think this kind of explains that it does
like it does affirm like the Quranic
like authority over the previous
scriptures and I think it just Yeah, I
would look I'd like to know get your
opinions on this. So just a second.
Yeah, I'll make sure I'm like I specify
a certain part because I think it may
like Is it verse 48 specifically that
you're talking about? I think from 46 to
48. Yeah. Yeah. Go on just a second.
Yeah. 46 to 48. I see. Is that what you
have? The I have uh Yeah, I have the
older like um not all the I have like
and excellent. I think these are the
ones that I and Kortoi I think, but I'm
not sure. Okay. I'm sorry. And this is
the first time I've like tried. I don't
know why I didn't get it like prepared.
So, I think this sums it up. It's It has
There's two readings for the verse.
Okay. What verse? I think it's the one
about the I am so sorry this taking too
long. Um, let the people of the gospel
Yeah, I found it. Let the people of the
gospel judge by what Allah revealed in
it. Okay, you can read the Arabic one if
you want, but I think it's like it sums
up in this one.
Um, no, that's not the one. It's like um
a different a slightly different like
reading for it. And one of them, so the
purpose reading shows the reason for
revelation and the command reading shows
the continued expectation or
responsibility. So that's what I came
down to. So basically one of them would
completely the command reading which is
I think the Jezen reading uh would
basically say yes it still confirms the
like it basically tells the Christians
to still judge by their books and the
purpose reading kind of shows the
opposite. So I don't want to like hang
all my like no thoughts about this on
like what it could be if that makes
sense. Yeah, I would say um so just just
in case anyone uh isn't getting this and
and I can say it so you can make sure
that I'm I'm understanding you
correctly. So you're saying that when
the Quran says, "Let the people of the
gospel judge by what Allah hath revealed
therein." Uh you're saying you can read
that as if it's a command. Hey people of
the gospel, you have to judge by your
book. in which case it would be
affirming the preservation and
continuing authority of the gospel. But
then there's also the purpose
interpretation which would be this was
Allah's purpose in revealing the verse.
So it wouldn't necessarily mean that it
has continuing authority because it's
talking about what Allah's purpose was.
Am I understanding that correctly?
Absolutely. Yes. Yes. Okay. And so
there's actually a variant reading there
as well. So there's like actually a
variant that does change the meaning
slightly, but it doesn't really affect
the argument. Yeah. So, uh I would just
say I would just say context-wise
context-wise this uh this purpose
interpretation makes no sense if it
isn't if it isn't somehow including the
command and that and the reason is this
is part of a passage and in 543 sort of
sets the tone and the standard where
Jews are trying to avoid um judging by
the Torah. So they go to Muhammad and
Allah says, "Why are they coming to you
when they have the Torah?" And then it
says, "If you don't judge, if you don't
judge by what Allah hath revealed,
you're no better than those who rebel."
And so that's the context and we have
the historical background on that in in
uh in Sunnah Abu Dh where Muhammad
actually tells the Jews, they set him on
the judgment cushion. So he's on the
judgment cushion. He's going to judge
this this situation. Muhammad says,
"Bring me the Torah." And it says they
bring him the Torah. So Jews bring, we
know it's actually talking about a
physical copy of the book for all the
Sajid lipum fans who think that the
Quran is not is not affirming texts that
were still available. Um but he says,
"Bring me the Torah." They bring him the
Torah. He gets off the judgment cushion.
He puts the Torah on the judgment
cushion. He says, "I believe in you and
in the one who revealed you." So it's
like multiple ways that he's confirming.
He's like, it's like a massive uh visual
demonstration of his perspective. No,
I'm not the judge. The Torah is the real
judge. I just tell I judge by telling
you to do what the Torah says. Uh and he
says, "I believe in you and in the one
who revealed you." And so if you want to
say, "Oh, believing in you means I only
believe in parts." Well, what do you do
with I believe in the one who revealed
you? Is that mean he just believe in
parts of Allah, too? So anyways, you
can't really avoid uh in 543, especially
with the historical background, that
Allah is saying Jews, you have to judge
by the Torah. You can't deviate from it.
If you try to deviate, the Quran is
going to send you right back to the
Torah. So, this is like this is like
extreme confirmation that this is this
is a command that this is a command.
You're not getting you're not getting
away from your book. The Quran is not
going to allow you to. So, that's the
context and you that's the context where
you eventually get 547. Let the people
of the gospel judge by what Allah has
revealed therein. So, 543 he's making
the Jews judge by the Torah. And then
right after that, he says, "Let the let
the people of the gospel judge by what
Allah revealed therein." So if it's if
it's going in a completely different
direction with what the meaning is, that
would make no sense. But then even
worse, you get the very next verse, the
very next verse where Allah says that
the Quran confirms the previous
scriptures and is a guardian. You see
what it means for the Quran to guard the
previous scriptures. It guards them from
people who are trying to deviate from
them. And then Allah says that he gave
different communities different laws so
that they would remain distinct groups
and they would compete with each other
in good works. What's that mean? It
means he's saying that everyone has to
follow the law of their group. Which
makes perfect sense if he just said that
Christians have to follow the gospel and
Jews have to follow the Torah. So I
would just say uh as far as the entire
context is concerned it it would make no
sense to say that the Quran is not
affirming the continuing authority
especially when you get to later in the
same chapter and you have verses uh 66
and 68. So 68 is the one that says let
the people of the gospel judge by what
Allah hath revealed. I mean uh I mean
not that that's 547 568 uh where he says
uh say to the people of the book you
have no ground to stand upon unless you
stand fast by the Torah the gospel and
all the revelation that has come to you
and so yeah you're just they're stuck
with the Quran is condemning Jews and
Christians not for having corrupt
scriptures but for not following the
scriptures that they have not obeying
the scriptures they have. And that makes
no sense unless the Quran still thinks
these uh are authoritative. I have
absolutely seen that theme going on in
the Quran even in the which it never
like even when they try to say that the
Christians or the Jews did something
wrong, they describe it as they did not
stick to their scriptures. And that
confuses me so much because like you're
telling me that the right thing they're
going to do is to stick to to their own
scriptures. But nowhere I can find like
even in this I was like I was looking
this like all the tips here for these
two verses for so long. I think for like
6 hours today to find one like like one
like scholar. Yes. one scholar that says
that what they did wrong was that they
like you know corrupted the scriptures
or that they didn't have it to even like
command with it or like rule with it but
it doesn't say that and it keeps
affirming like this says it's talking
about confirming what came before the
Torah um like to like Jesus about Jesus
and then it says this emphasizes the
gospel by the way this is not me writing
this is the tier but I just wrote it
here so that I can see it this emp
emphasizes the that the gospel did not
oppose the Torah, but rather affirmed
its truth. So, we should like take this
and apply it to the Quran. So,
basically, I'll have to say that this
emphasizes that the the the gospel uh
sorry, the Quran did not oppose the
gospel and it doesn't make sense. And
what's like I I think the question is
like if I see it this way, why am I like
still confused about it? Is basically
not just misunderstanding or like the
whole like it it's it kind of makes it
it's I'm sorry. I can't for my words.
It's just that I don't want to be like
in the fault of misunderstanding
something that is complicated. Uh to the
point where it leads me to eternal
damnation just because I didn't make
enough effort or because I thought I was
better than God's words, if that makes
any sense at all. Yeah. You're saying
you're saying you're saying you want to
be careful. These are matters of eternal
significance. So you're trying to be as
careful as possible. No, that makes
perfect sense. Yeah. And it's not I mean
it looks like you're doing exactly what
we're doing. So we've been with David
and uh Avery. We've been going through
the entire Quran starting in chapter 1.
We're currently in chapter 7. We're
about to be on chapter 8. And we've been
going through every single verse verse
by verse by verse noting down every
single reference to the Torah to the
Injil anything related to the Bible at
all. Right. And we've been looking at
the commentaries as well and kind of
like similar to what you're doing here.
So what you're going to find when you
keep doing this is is that it's going to
keep affirming over and over and over
and over and over again these same ideas
and you're not going to find anything
that gives any argument against it. So
you're not going to find anything that
says the Torah is corrupt or the injil
is corrupt or these are not actually
from God anymore or anything like that.
You're going to find the opposite that
is continuously being confirmed and
appealed to and that you should believe
in these books. The problem is though
what you're going to find out and you
know you're reading through the through
Matthew and through John you're going to
find out that actually you read these
books and you can't be a Muslim and
believe in this and this you can only
believe in one or the other right and
the thing is if you if you believe in
the other the Quran well then you can't
because it says to believe in the other
so it's like you're in this this is what
we call the dilemma so you're kind of
stuck between these two. So, um, yeah,
it sounds like you are being very
careful and you're putting in a lot of
research and obviously you're you're
reading the Bible as well and I'm sure
you're praying as well. Um, sounds like,
you know, you're you're heading in the
right direction. I mean, you're not you
shouldn't be faulted at all. You should
be we we commend you. We we want all
Muslims to do this. We want all Muslims
to do this. You have found exactly what
we found. We went through it very
carefully. This corruption
not is not originally Islam at all. This
corruption idea comes later in Muslim
history when Muslims actually started
reading the Bible and thought uhoh. This
book is not what Muhammad told us. This
book is not the what the Quran says. So
something must have changed then because
the Quran says I affirm you. So it's
like you're being gaslit a bit. It's
like this book is meant to be the same
as similar and it's not. But they
actually come at it from that we believe
Muhammad. So the books must have been
changed. Whereas what happened was the
books have always been the same.
Muhammad just never read it. He assumed
that they they have this similar to him
because had told him when he first
became thought he became a prophet that
you are the one we've been waiting for.
You're in our books. So he believed in
in it all the time and he kept saying
come to the Torah, come to the gospel.
I'm in it. And he affirmed the books. So
he believed in a lie and then Muslims
have been believing in it all the time
and then they cracked open the Bible.
They thought now the truth is something
else. Now they they said, "Oh, it must
have been changed enough." You with me?
I I I actually found that it's Yeah, I'm
with you. I'm just I I think if I look
at it from a logical point of view or a
historical point of view, I'll have to
like realize that the Quran existing
kind of de diminish, if that's the right
word, the New Testament. It absolutely
like destroys it and it still speaks of
it. So it can't like you can't find any
information about the New Testament in
the Quran. It doesn't exist. You don't
know anything about Jesus. That's why it
kind of bothers me when I hear someone
says like my beloved prophet Jesus. And
I'm like I don't even I didn't even know
anything about him until I started like
looking at it historically. You're not
you don't you don't find any information
about him except that he's going to rule
the world at the end of the the the like
time. And it doesn't make sense for me
to like ignore all historical aspects.
But at the same time there's this like I
don't know I'm bound to like consider
that I'm just in the wrong and at the
same time I don't know how to explain it
but I think um it's not a theological
struggle as much as it's like a root of
beliefs ingraded in like the nature you
don't think you have you can't think I
feel like Muslims are too comfortable
with their religion to even consider
this at the slightest which is why in
their like I don't know yeah it's just
I'm I'm trying to pick I think it's not
theological issue as more as if it's
like as someone said I think I was I was
watching a lot for you guys and someone
said um I I listen to the Quran and it
makes me comfortable or it makes sense
to me that this is from God and
unfortunately I'm I'm guilty the same
thing like I listen to the Quran and it
affects me. It affects me not in a good
or a bad way. It just affects me as like
hey these cannot be not the words of God
and it just it controls some like some
of the narrative inside of your head or
like some of your judgment. So either
you go with your mind or you go with
your like I don't know instinct or like
I don't know heart. I'm not sure what it
is. Yeah. It's um it's bra it's I
wouldn't call it brainwashing but it's
like what's familiar? It's cultish. It's
more cultish. Yeah. It's it's um you
grew up with mom, dad, Islam, and it's
more like it's part of me. It's
familiar. When I when you hear it, you
think of home, you think of childhood,
you think of all these things, and it
pulls on that part of you. But that part
is not true. Like it's it's a you need
that's why you need the Lord Jesus to
come in and break that. It's bondage.
It's attachment. It's like being
attached to a a husband who like beats
you every day, but that's all you've
known. So you don't know how to get out
or something like that or so something
that is not true like like addiction
like addiction like someone who loves
the bottle he's familiar with the with
the with the bottle or with the drugs
with drugs or something he can't wait to
get home and and drink or you know but
that doesn't make it true and you have
to break the attachment but that's why
you need God. Yeah. Like you're saying
it's not just a theological thing. This
is emotional. It's spiritual. And if you
think about it like in terms of
addiction, right? someone who let's say
they they get like these struggles to go
back to their addictions. They're trying
to pull away from it. Let's say a
certain situation happens and it brings
them back to oh you know I used you know
when I used to deal I used to deal this
problem this way I used to do drugs or
drink alcohol or something like that but
it's comfortable. It's like the way it's
the way to medicate out of the
situation. So they have like these
triggers and so what you're saying is
like oh look you know when I hear the
Quran it reminds me when I was a kid and
my grandmother used to play the Quran or
used to you know whatever it's like you
have these memories cuz you're human and
these are like you know we're humans and
we build like connections and emotions
to memories and things remind us of our
past etc. You have these emotional
connections to things. Same thing with
people with addictions though but
doesn't make it right. So someone might
like when they go through a hard time,
they might all of a sudden turn to
alcohol and drink alcohol and that's way
to comfort themselves. And that might be
like it gives them a temporary sort of
comfort, but that doesn't make it right,
right? It's not healthy. Doesn't make it
true. So it's like a fix temporarily.
Like yeah, it'll get you back to that
state where you're kind of like in La La
Land and you feel comfortable or
whatever, but it's not actually a true
fix. It's not a healthy fix. So and it's
designed that way, Jane. That's why they
do the Quran where they do it in a
melody because it pulls on the emotion.
That's why they five times a day. It's
like you hear it. You hear it all the
time. It becomes part of you. Uh and you
know it's on it's in they they they
invade your life with it. You know your
mom speaks of it, your grandma speaks of
it. You you you you say something. You
say the name of you know you say bisah
before you eat. You say do this before
you do this. You say this before you go
to the toilet. You say this before you
leave. when you come back, it's designed
that way so that when you leave it, you
feel, well, what what's my life about? I
need to go back to it. Well, that's
that's indoctrination. And it's like you
say, it's cultish.
Yes. And and Jesus can fill those voids
that you have, those emotional whatever
it is that's drawing you back. You like
you're going through a difficult time.
You hear the Quran reminds you of these
good times, these good memories. That
can all be healed in Jesus. So, there's
a solution for what you're going
through. the Quran and whatever else
you're going with like it's like just
like someone who's like on drugs or
something. They're just going back to
something. It's not a healthy way to
deal with their problems, but it's a way
to deal with their problems, but it's
not a healthy way. But there's a true
way and there's a good way and there's a
healthy way. And that's, you know, what
you're offered in Jesus. And remember,
you I just don't know. I'm sorry. I I
thought I interrupted someone. I just um
I think it's it comes down to the fact
that I'm I don't follow like I don't
think I see I see your point and I see
like I think you're actually correct but
at the same time I think of too many
like like aspects of this. One of them
is uh a loving God or a god that like um
like um stirs up emotions inside of you.
um could be more of a like it would be
me like putting a fantasy in life. So I
don't follow that. I know that that's a
a really harsh thing to say, but I feel
like I have to follow like the truth or
like the logic before anything else
because if I let my emotions control me,
I think it doesn't make any point. It
doesn't like doesn't mean I'm going to
the real path. So that's what I've been
actually doing. Like I've been
researching the whole thing about like
nine I think eight months now and I'm
just like I'm struggling right now. I
don't know like I really thought that I
was going to be able to comprehend or
like form one like good sentence. I had
a lot of questions as well, but I feel
like it's just getting too much day by
day and it's getting to a point where
logic doesn't work, faith doesn't work,
praying doesn't work, and it just makes
it and I know that this could be
foreigner to a foreign concept to
non-Muslims, but it just it's it's a
very difficult position to try and get
out of this. And at the same time, if we
don't follow like the the I don't know,
I feel like I lost my train of thoughts.
You have the comfort of what you know.
You have the comfort of what you know
and then you're faced with like, okay,
do I follow the truth? And the truth,
the cost of the truth, there could be
consequences of that. You know, you
might lose your family, you might lose
what you're familiar with, you might
lose your job, you might lose your
friends if you follow the truth, but and
so the question is like what are you
willing to do? Like are you willing to
follow the truth no matter the cost, no
matter the consequences, right? That's
what it comes down to. Now, we're not
asking you to like do anything right
now. We're not saying to like, you know,
leave your home or something, but we're
saying like that's what it comes down
to, right? Cuz we're talking, you
mentioned before, this is about eternal
life. So, if it comes down to those
things, like, you know, are you willing
to follow the truth no matter what,
right? That's I'm not saying you have to
answer it, but I'm saying that's what
you have to think about. You're saying
and you know, right? Yeah. Like you have
the comfort of like, you know, like,
okay, I can just keep doing what I know,
what I'm familiar with, and I can just,
you know, whatever. But are you you're
not really going to ever be happy
because you know that this is not true.
Yeah. You're never going to you know too
much. I always say this when people come
to a point when they know too much. You
think it's comfortable, but it actually
isn't. As you can't stay Muslim and know
too much because anytime you're going to
say you're going to recite that verse or
hear it about the sept, for example, the
Sabbath, you're going to think, "Oh, oh,
it's not actually true." And when you
hear about the Torah, all the hundreds
of verses about the Torah and the
gospel, you think, "Oh, but they don't
actually say what we think they say and
you're going to your life. I'm telling
you, you can't." I like the promises of
Sorry, I really like I think there's a
delay, so that's why I keep interrupting
you guys. I'm sorry. No, it's okay. Go
on. It's just the promises of eternal
hell. Like it's so constant and it
happens a lot in the Quran. It just
Yeah. The punishment of the grave. I
know many look we we talk to ex-Muslims
all the time and that's one of the main
things, believe it or not. Like a lot of
people may not know this, but that's one
of the main things that ex-Muslims deal
with. They're they're traumatized by the
punishment of the grave. Like it's a
real thing that emotionally scars
people. And Jesus can heal you from
that. And he does. But there's a big
struggle for a lot of ex-Muslims. This
torment of the grave, the torture of the
grave. like whenever you go past a
graveyard, you're like scared and it it
has a hu we understand it has a huge
emotional effect and um it's not it's
not like we're not trying to minimalize
it at all, you know? It's it's a real
thing, but there can be healing for that
too, right? There can be healing for
that, too. Yeah. It's a it's a book that
keeps threatening you like I'm going to
do this to you. I'm going to throw you
in hell every two. Even as a believer, I
used to get annoyed at this. Like, okay,
you're going to tell you said you're
going to throw them in hell 10 times.
Can you tell me something? I'm a
believer. I need help now. Yeah.
I I'm so sorry, Doc. I actually made a
friend joke to my friend. She's a
Christian and I told her, "I dare you.
Like, I'm going to open a random page in
the Quran and you'll look at it and
you're going to hell in that verse or
like in that page." And yeah, it is
true. You can open any any chapter you
want, any page you want, and someone is
promised hell. Yeah, it's fear. It's
it's um it's fear. But what God says in
the Bible is we haven't given you a we
were not given a spirit of fear but of
love sound mind power love and sound
mind. So uh that's not God really. The
one who rules with fear is is Satan. So
again you know anytime you're going to
read any of these verses you're going to
think oh man. Um so I would say look I I
I I think you're already out if you're
not already or if you're going to stay
in you're going to be very
uncomfortable. So, you don't actually
have a choice in my opinion. If you want
to be if you want to continue to be
sane, you don't have a choice but to
leave. It's it's it's a question that's
been like asked for a long time now. And
I don't know, every time I feel like
this is I don't know if that's a
universal thing about like Muslims who
turn apostates or whatever or they
convert to another religion, but every
day I feel like I'm another person like
every day comes and I'm like feeling
some days I rebuked it completely. But
then I came back and I was the like I'm
so scared so sorry at the same time I
have I actually have a theological
question or like I don't know what kind
of question to you guys. Um and like
it's about like when you see the horrors
of the world. So um coming from a Muslim
background, every time we see something
bad happening in the world, I see people
around me who just like I don't know f
like you know just looking at these
people and being like these people are
going to be judged by God and these
people are going to suffer in hell. And
I know that this is cruel because I
really don't wish anyone hell but at the
same time some people in the world or
some things in the world that are
happening it just makes me think hell
actually is kind of fair. So, I don't
know like if I would be comfortable with
the fact that these people would do
these awful things, but at the same time
because they like like I don't know if
they're, you know, just that's why makes
sense for me like with the Islam how
like it works when it like punishes
people or like bad people. Yeah. We have
this this there's a judgment in
Christianity. There's heaven and hell
and God is all just. Yeah. So, it's not
just something in Islam. God will judge
these people who have you know
unrepentant people who are you know
turned away from God who are doing these
ungodly things evil acts they will be
judged and their punishment will be just
so they're not like escaping punishment
um in Christianity or something you know
there there's hope for them you know
they can hope they they can have a if
they repent if they really truly believe
uh but those who do not um there is a
punishment for them and you know God
will deal with them justly. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't have an issue with a punishment.
A punishment being there from God. My
issue is if someone keeps putting the
threatening with hell 24/7. That's not
from God. God doesn't the motivation for
me to follow God as a believer is not
hell. That's my issue. So someone with
punishment is not God. And by the way,
Muhammad actually he taught that there
are people that are predestined to
heaven and hell. Not just that people
are there for their bad actions, but
even children who haven't done any evil,
babies who haven't done any evil.
Muhammad said that some of them are for
heaven and some some for heaven and some
are for hell. And he he rebuked Aisha.
He said, well, he didn't rebuke, but he
said he he corrected her and said that
you can't say that a child who dies is
going to necessarily go to heaven. You
don't know that. He said he said it
could be the other way. It could be that
Allah made this, you know, baby or this
child for the hellfire. So even we're
talking about children who have done no
right or no wrong nor have done no evil
in Islam in Islam they have there's
there's this predestination that is
completely unfair and unjust. Yeah that
makes that makes sense and we can send
you material on that as well. We can
send you material on that as well. Yeah.
Yeah. I actually I've already thought
about this before the whole
predestination thing and it didn't make
sense to me. Uh just sometimes I feel
like I'm struggling with two gods that
I'm trying to choose one like an old and
I know that this is like in both ways
offensive but I just got to say like
sometimes it feels like there's an old
angry god and then a loving god and I
have to choose between both logically
without being like I don't know what's
the word like um without like putting my
desires or heart into it because if I
did I'm going to choose based on like
not knowledge something other than
knowledge which just It doesn't make
sense to me. That's why it's like a
struggle. But thank you guys so much.
It's I know that I actually I lost all
my points once I started this, but it's
like 2:00 a.m. now, so I think it's just
I'm I'm all powered down. Makes sense.
Makes sense. No, we appreciate you
coming, James. Yeah, we'll speak. Yeah,
to meet you. And yeah, we're happy to
talk to you. So yeah, feel free to
follow up, email, and uh we'll try to
help you with whatever we can. Same.
We'll pray for you. Thank you so much. I
just want to say something to David.
You're a blessing from God. Thank you so
much for everything. I know that people
don't give you credit, much credit or
enough credit, and I see all the jokes
that go on and I hate that you're
amazing. You have no idea. And by the
way, um I I actually I knew you. You're
you're the beginning for like all of
this. I watched a video for the you know
finding uh seeking Allah finding Jesus
by Nabil Koreshi and then I knew you and
I didn't know that you're going to like
be as like big as you turned out to be
because when I watched that I only made
like my main focus was Nabil because he
taught things like um like academically
like in a source like yeah so but then I
started watching your videos and you're
amazing. God bless you. Whatever you're
doing, you're doing for the right
reason. And I believe that's enough. So,
thank you. Yeah. And yeah, thank you,
Avery. Thank you, Jay. And thank you,
you guys. All right. Take care, J. All
right. So, that was Jane. What you What
do you guys think? Uh, DLC, your
perspective. What do you think so far?
Um, where she's at? Um, I know you guys
talk you're an ex-Muslim. You guys talk
with ex-Muslims. What What do you think?
She's too smart, too knowledgeable to
stay in that religion and stay sane.
She's going to leave very quickly if
she's left already by her heart. Yeah.
Um but we're just going to pray about
her coming to the Lord Jesus because
that's the aim. I don't want her to just
leave and be in nothing. But I I believe
she will and we pray she's she's honest
and she wants the truth. So when the L
when someone wants the truth, the Lord
doesn't let you down. Exactly. Yeah. But
while you guys while you guys were uh
talking um about how Islam ingrains this
fear of hell into you, conditions you
with this fear of hell so that even like
after you leave it or something like
that, it's still, you know, it's still
part of you. Uh I was thinking like like
think of the flip side in Islam. Uh if
you believe it, you get to spend
eternity deflowering virgins. Like how
is it not how is it not obvious that
this guy just took Okay, here's your
biggest fear. I'll threaten you with
that if you don't believe my religion
and what what are you guys absolutely
obsessed with? Oh, defflowering virgins.
That that's oh then that's what the
eternity how is it like right? How's it
not obvious right what this guy's doing?
But yeah, exactly. It's very obvious.
All right, so we got to cover super
chats. Um, Holy Hex says, "Love
listening